hello i am jake gyllenhaal i'm yaya
abdulmatein ii and this is first
impressions for lab bible
what you got
you cute oh
ah
oh say more it's like
it's careful
[Music]
oh you cute
uh i went to laguardia with with timmy
chalamet um
the nails
julie roberts what the [ __ ]
what's the song is it [ __ ] yeah how does
it go do you want the explicit version
always
yeah always yeah
you got it oh my goodness
oh i don't know how to do this
i don't oh you're doing an impersonation
i don't know this one is
this is
the supreme
leader
okay yoda no what
are you guys as confused as i am really
hope
that i end up being in this movie
[Music]
she's not gonna get it it was tom hardy
oh god help me that's tom hardy how does
bane sound i can't do bait because i
need to know if i was like like you were
way off i thought you were yoda
i thought it was yoda
um
it's okay what the [ __ ] just happened
this there
what in the [ __ ] that yeah we gonna
leave it
together we're gonna leave it
hello how are you
oh okay
okay okay oh wow it took it all up but
let me tell you it took a lot to get
there though right i mean it took you
you had to get through it
so um like like
is it de niro
all right guys i'm here with here with
my buddy jake and uh we're gonna i got a
special um special announcement just for
just for the special fans out there
we're gonna screen uh one of my thousand
movies coming out right now on netflix
we did we did number one we just crossed
two trillion screen streams okay there
we go buddy if you smell
down
if you smell
you i started this game
feeling like you were one of the kindest
calmest coolest people i'm gonna leave
this room afraid i'm afraid of you okay
oh hey hello this is my friend luigi
hello
hello this is
did you grow up playing
video games oh yeah for sure then what's
wrong with you
that was perfect it wasn't perfect it
was it was it was mario but it wasn't it
wasn't
it wasn't just mario it was super mario
oh my god jake jake jake how you doing
bro jake what are you doing jake
what are you doing sexiest man in the
world all right
you recently played cowboy in the movie
i did a dirty dress okay okay there we
go there we go okay um
this is a weird game that's good that's
good
never guess what this one is oh my god
you will
never guess what this one is
i got it
it's yoda it's yoda oh my god that's so
weird in your pot and i'm like horrible
but i'm crushing this game right now
all right all right all right oh uh
uh is that
brett bradley no i mean no no no no no
no no no no no no no bathroom yeah
you ready yeah let's put a smile on that
face
every time every time
oh ernie no come on dude oh girl
let's put a smile on that face
is it more sinister no i felt kind still
get out of here let's put a smile
that's the joker you know that okay
what does bane sound like what does bane
sound like
oh
yeah yeah yeah i was born
in the dark it doesn't sound
um i don't
like ryan reynolds at all
i can't do this you can you can will and
you will